throughout its long history
our earth has been inhabited by life
forms totally different from each other
some of them looked like fantasy
creatures incarnate while others would
appear more or less usual to us
dinosaurs were undoubtedly the most
well-known and impressive creatures of
the past of course
they dominated the earth's biosphere for
as long as
145 million years giving rise to
countless species and forms
however about 66 million years ago our
planet changed its inhabitants yet again
as a result of a global disaster whose
details are still quite obscure now
practically all animals weighing over 25
kilograms were wiped off the face of the
earth within an extremely short period
by geological standards
the vacated expanses were promptly taken
over by new dwellers
mammals
in the course of the incessant struggle
for survival there evolved more and more
new species until a unique creature
appeared on the scene
instead of adapting to relentless nature
it decided to rather adapt nature to its
needs
this wasn't the biggest strongest or
fastest creature either
but how come it became the king of all
nature
[Music]
the cretaceous paleogene mass extinction
event heralded the beginning of a new
geological era
the cenozoic
having started 66 million years ago it
is still going on
in the course of all this period the
earth's surface underwent global
transformations and offered its expanses
to a great multitude of amazing
creatures
the first period of the new era was
dubbed the paleogene
it started immediately after the
disaster that wiped off dinosaurs
and lasted for 43 million years
our planet's appearance dramatically
changed in this time
india crossed the ocean and virtually
round into the south coast of asia
the himalayas rose their peaks up to the
heavens
and the antarctic began to grow its vast
ice shield
in the first 10 million years the
earth's biosphere was recovering from
the fateful blow
with the old masters gone agile and
viable animals mammals quickly spread
across the ecological niches vacated by
them
looking for new forms life evolved and
produced the duo andrew sarkis
the giant and rigid indrick ethereum
and the aquatic archaeoceti the
prehistoric ancestors of today's whales
many of these fascinating creatures
vanished without a trace while others
evolved to adapt to the changeable
conditions
about 23 million years ago the paleogene
was succeeded by the neogene which
lasted around 20 million years
it is divided into two unequal epochs
the longer one of which is called the
maya scene
this was a time of unhurried and
consistent cooling
ice caps on the earth gradually grew
while the climate became cooler and
drier
the global sea level was falling and
mountain ridges like the alps and the
andes on the contrary were rising higher
as a result of this process the
mediterranean sea was cut off from the
global ocean and almost dried up
in its place there remained vast
lowlands covered by salty desert
according to some estimates temperature
in some of its areas reached 80 degrees
celsius while the atmospheric pressure
at the bottom of this basin was over one
and a half times the value of what we're
used to
just a few small lakes with extremely
salty water were scattered across the
bleak lifeless desert
in that epoch the vast expanses of our
planet were home to a great number of
bizarre creatures
gigantopithecus
an enormous man-like ape related to
orangutans over three meters in height
and with a body mass of up to half a ton
forced its way through dense asian
rainforests
and teledon
an angular predator and scavenger the
size of a bull
terrified stabbed ballis as for the
ocean its depths were dominated by
megalodon the largest carnivorous shark
in the history of the earth
[Music]
slightly over 5 million years ago the
area which is now known as gibraltar was
stunned by tremendous earthquake
the rocky dam that had separated the
mediterranean sea from the atlantic
ocean for hundreds of thousands of years
finally gave way
and millions of tons of water gushed
into the gigantic lifeless lowlands
according to estimates the force of the
flow was forty thousand times that of
the niagara falls
and it took only two years for the sea
to fill up again
at the same time thousands of tons of
salt were buried under layers of sand
and rock of remarkable thickness and
that's where it remains to this day
[Music]
this tremendous event dubbed the
zanclean flood
is considered to be the beginning of the
pliocene e-park that was to last for two
million seven hundred and forty-five
thousand years
by that time the continents had drifted
to stay in the places we're used to
seeing them but some relief features
were just starting to form
for example north and south america was
still separated by a wide strait at the
beginning of the epoch
and the rocky mountains were just
starting to grow
the earth's climate in the first half of
the pliocene was comparatively warm
our planet's average temperature was two
to three degrees higher than it is now
although these extra degrees were not
distributed across the planet evenly
the climate in the tropical latitudes
resembled that of today but northern
areas were much warmer
the arctic was not covered in ice
permanently and dense conifer forests
reached the northernmost areas of
eurasia
still it should be borne in mind that
the continent's border used to lie
slightly more to the south than it does
now because the sea level at the time
was an average 25 meters higher than
today on account of the higher
temperature
meanwhile today's humans first ancestors
inhabited the african continent
adipithecus
sahilanthropus
and doron
the unearthed remains of these ancient
primates date four to six million years
back
their bodybuild is still very far from
that of humans
there is no doubt that these creatures
were advanced apes rather than humans
but still they had taken the first step
in evolution of a new life
features of their discovered skeletons
reveal a tendency to developing an
upright posture even though tree
climbing habits manifested themselves
very clearly still
as for these creatures cranial capacity
it was bigger than that of chimpanzees
and the teeth structure was similar to
that of later species
what was it that forced the ancient
primates change so much
a possible reason could be that
approximately three million years ago
the continental plains of north and
south america collided and caused a
rapid rise of rocks
the strait between the two continents
was cut off by the isthmus of panama
which blocked the passage of warm ocean
waters at around the same time the rocky
mountains considerably gained in height
thus forming a barrier between the
atlantic and the pacific air currents
with all these factors combined the
earth gradually cooled and some parts of
it grew to be icebound
the north pole was gripped with an ice
shield
greenland started to build up tons of
ice cap
while the areas of african forests
shrank giving way to steps and savannas
treetops make great habitats they're
safe and comfortable and provide one
with plenty of food
this is what ancient primates agreed on
they adapted to the tree climbing
lifestyle extremely well
however
the global climate change eliminated the
greater part of the african forests
thousands of species lost the habitats
they were used to
and so many of them vanished off the
face of the earth
others were forced to adapt to survive
the new conditions
today the savannah concept is the most
developed and well-grounded hypothesis
of anthropogenesis
according to this concept the deficit of
their usual food and lack of woods
forced our ancestors out into the
savanna riddled with unknown dangers
by this time they were already capable
of moving around on two legs and using
primitive tools
just like all man-like apes
these skills were vital for survival in
the new conditions
easily digestible fruit and plants were
sparse in the savanna and rough grass
and leaves were inedible for the
primates
tapping into animal sources of food
became key to survival
however one is supposed to be fast and
strong to hunt successfully and this is
what our ancestors lacked
only developing an upright posture could
give them the necessary edge in these
circumstances
upright walking not only increased the
speed of movement
but also allowed sighting both potential
game and danger from far off
when the body is in the vertical
position
strong hands with prehensile fingers are
free
so a stick or a sharpened stone can be
used much easier
by forming small tribes
the new inhabitants of the savannah
could hunt or at the very least take the
kill of other predators away from them
by force
it is assumed that the necessity to
coordinate actions in the process
stimulated the development of the brain
and primitive speech
gradual evolution in the course of
several million years endowed the
ape-like cardiopyths and say
philanthropists with human features
that's how australopithecus came to be
this agile smart but not very big
creature appeared on the territory of
africa in the period from 4.2 to 1.8
million years ago
analysis of their fossilized remains
revealed them to have been 120 to 140
centimeters in height and to have
weighed around 40 kilograms
unlike other primates australopithecus
moved around primarily on two legs
although its posture remained stooped
as for its brain even though it was
larger than that of human-like apes the
differences in its inner makeup were
minuscule
it is now that australopits lived in
tribes and could cooperate for hunting
and fighting enemies
research shows that early species used
only objects close at hand while later
ones learned to make the most basic and
primitive tools to work and defend
themselves with
in spite of all that most individuals
didn't live to be older than 20 because
of illnesses injuries and wild animals
attacks
apparently the predators of that time
saw australopithecus exclusively as a
food source
back then dinofelis was around
a large saber-toothed cat distantly
related to smiley tantini which were to
emerge later
diggings revealed that it preferred
living not far from australopith's camps
it clearly saw them as easy prey
slightly larger than today's leopards
dino felis was more thick set and more
powerfully built
with a weight reaching 120 kilograms
these predators were around 70
centimeters tall
it is next to impossible to fight this
kind of animal single-handed
and probably the beast could be driven
away by our ancestors only by giant
effort
of course dinofelis hunted not only
australopiths
antelopes or wild boars for example were
also part of its diet
most animals inhabiting the earth of
that time resemble today's species
however there were some real monsters
among them too
for example in north and south america
there lived several species of
flightless predatory birds of the forest
rocketdye family whose largest
individuals reached three meters in
height
their skulls measured as much as 75
centimeters with a powerful beak
accounting for most of it
thanks to their ranger legs the birds
were able to develop great speeds
fortunately mankind didn't have to face
these monsters as the forest rockets
died out completely around a hundred
thousand years ago
much earlier than america's first
ancient tribes had settled there
the ancient jungles meanwhile were home
to another giant
an elephant-like beast dinotherium whose
mass reached 14 tons and whose height
measured three and a half to four and a
half meters
of all land mammals ever to tread the
surface of our planet only intricate
ethereum and mammoths were larger
these distant relatives of elephants are
thought to have inhabited the forests of
asia and africa subsisting mainly on
tree foliage
their trunks were probably shorter and
thicker than those of the elephant and
the most outstanding feature in their
appearance is their long massive tusks
protruding from the mandible
two million five hundred and eighty
eight thousand years ago
a tremendous event occurred which got
the name of the gauss matayama reversal
the earth's magnetic poles swapped
places and all the magnetic lines
changed their directions
the transformation was accompanied by a
weakening of the planet's magnetic field
which decreased by four times
this means that cosmic rays lethal to
all living things could now reach the
earth's surface
and even though this phenomenon was
around for just approximately 15 000
years which is negligible by geological
standards it caused several species to
massively die out
this magnetic reversal is seen as a
milestone marking the beginning of a new
geological period
the quaternary
it is divided into two epochs the first
of which is called the pleistocene
it started
[Music]
258 000 years ago and finished just 12
000 years ago
periodic cooling accompanied by the
growth of ice caps was typical for the
climate of that time
in between ice ages temperatures grew
and dice caps melted which made the sea
level to rise
these frequent fluctuations in the
climate
forced living things to adapt to these
changes quickly and stimulated the
process of evolution
gradually evolving australopiths gave
rise to two large branches of primates
parathropus an extinct genus today and
homo among others represented by today's
humans
however the three branches coexisted for
a considerably long time in the
competitive conditions of a struggle for
survival
the evolutionary way from higher
primates to humans was not straight and
clear-cut
there were plenty of dead ends and forks
at least 24 different species roamed our
planet at different times whose
representatives could be referred to as
humans to this or that degree
the evolutionary process of humans and
our ancestors is always paid a lot of
attention to
and details are constantly being updated
it should be borne in mind that
evolution is a very slow process at
least two to three million years is
needed for species to completely part
their ways and into breed to give rise
to viable hybrids
meanwhile the entire history of the homo
the genus including today's human
species amounts to around 2.5 million
years
with our most ancient ancestors taken
into account
this figure can be pretty much doubled
also many populations inhabited
neighboring areas which means that there
were probably quite a lot of hybrids out
there in the natural world
it should also be born in mind that
intraspecies variation in humans is
quite high there are noticeable
differences between men and women and
people of different traces also
demonstrate clearly diverse features it
is thought that ancient species divided
into races as well some of which may
erroneously have been classified as
separate species by scientists
new archaeological finds help to correct
these errors and supply important
details to our knowledge
in spite of all their progressive
features australipits were raped to a
greater degree than they were humans
the first universally recognized
representative of the human species was
the so-called homo habilis or handyman
digging show that handyman lived on the
territory of africa in the period from
2.3 to 1.5 million years ago it had a
more developed brain than
australopithecus and was able to make
primitive labor tools
the height of this species individuals
was around 1.2 meters
with a mass likely to be 50 kilos or
less
interestingly it was the first creature
whose big toe was located in one row
with the other toes as is the case with
today's humans
this could be seen as evidence of
complete adaptation to an upright
posture
another important parameter was the
structure of the jaws which could
indicate a gradually developing ability
to produce articulate speech
[Music]
later evolution produced homo agusta or
working man about 2 million years ago
and homo erectus or upright man
different scientists classify them
either as close evolutionary branches or
as subspecies of one species
in the course of migrations these
representatives of the human race
settled on the territories of africa
asia and europe which stimulated
numerous evolutionary branches one of
them eventually produced homo sapiens
ancient people whether neanderthals or
homo sapiens lived in tribes and
practiced a nomadic lifestyle
living by gathering and hunting they
were forced to constantly migrate and
move to new unexplored areas
in this manner primitive tribes
gradually settled all over the
continents except the antarctica
around 50 000 years ago exploration of
australia began and about 24 000 years
ago people reached north america for the
first time via the burying
isthmus the spread of primitive tribes
across the globe coincided with mass
extinctions of the megafauna in the
pleistocene in the period from 50 000 to
10 000 years ago mammoths and giant
sloth megatherium vanished off the face
of the planet
followed by saber-toothed cats and other
predators who were unable to keep up the
fierce competition for food perhaps
humans would have met the same fate but
around 12 000 years ago an ice age came
to its end and our planet's climate
became warmer and more humid
the fertile valleys of mesopotamia and
the niles estuary allowed our ancestors
to lead a non-migratory gathering
lifestyle and later to form fully
fledged agricultural communities after
the so-called neolithic revolution
that was the end of the pleistocene
which heralded a new epoch in the
history of our planet
the holocene was a time of robust growth
of the human civilization technical and
social progress
destructive wars and ecological
disasters
by choosing a unique path of evolution
first steps on completely new and
unexplored territories beyond our planet
only time will show what this path will
lead to
dear friends
the topic of the genesis of man is still
full of unsolved mysteries and secrets
if you have anything to say about it
feel free to share your opinion in the
comments
your active participation means a lot to
us because we put our hearts in every
new episode and try to make each one
interesting and informative we're always
happy to get likes and positive comments
from you
this motivates us to make new videos
faster
let's keep in touch
[Music]
you